Hello again this is Dr. Kevin Cutters with Cutters clinic live and other podcast for you
and today it's exciting because we're going to talk about some emotional well-being with health issues
I have as our guest Cheryl Hanna she is with Kadesionics integrative health care in Prince George
British Columbia way up north north of Minnesota I think right quite good but probably not too much
temperature difference no it's a beautiful day today is it yeah we got a nice sunny day but it's
two degrees so so Cheryl tell me a little let's start with introducing you to our audience tell
us about you and how you got to be doing what you're doing right now well I've always been
interested in natural health care I raised my children doing the whole whole foods cooking
nutritional approach to to supporting the body's function and health and I have 12 children
and when I got pregnant with baby number 11 I broke out in this horrific rash that went from my neck
all the way down to my knees and I could tell you within five minutes if I'd eaten the wrong thing
because I was just starting to have reactions to everything and so basically what happened was
I had an incredible yeast bloom of candida sure progesterone feeds candida and with that many babies
under my belt yeah my body was just right and unhappy conventional medications didn't have much
to offer that wasn't somewhat toxic to my baby as well so that was kind of ruled out and I
I happened to run across a fellow who uses something called muscle response monitoring or applied
kinesiology or muscle testing and within a couple of weeks he had me strained around using natural
herbs and supplements and I was hooked from that point and went okay how do I learn how to do this
and then things just kind of progressed from there oh that's great what is so this that was how
many years ago that was nearly 20 years ago oh goodness started on this path yeah so what is your
practice specializing now well we cover all sorts of things but I've been working on everything from
brain injury to tumors to learning disabilities and one of the things that seems to be coming up a lot
from lately is working with people who have PTSD depression and emotional trauma that they haven't
been able to overcome using conventional talk therapies and counseling stuff so when we specialize
in cancers you know but when we talk about causes of cancer always emotional uh there's an
emotional piece to it you can say I don't think there's this early usually emotions as a major
cause but there's a piece to that and as far as overcoming the disease and healing from it if you
don't address the emotional piece of just you know it's a scary thing when you hear the seaweed yeah
many people get scared to do even a treatment protocol that they don't really want to do or they
when they if they were thinking correctly and then there's all sorts of fear and anxiety that
they have to go through how would you take somebody with a serious diagnosis and kind of walk
through a procedure because they don't have to be in your office right you can do this at a distance
how would you walk through somebody with a cancer diagnosis to help them uncover that emotional side
that they need to deal with uh well the the really interesting thing about muscle testing and the way
muscles work is that they're directly tied into our our nervous system and our endocrine system
and they we can detect a change in the state of the muscle through testing and depending on the
input we give it and the input input can be verbal so I can ask a yes-no type of question and get
a response back from the body and what that allows me to do is to to actually address things at the
causal level as opposed to just dealing with the symptom so some of the research that's now coming
out through things like polyvagal therapy and stuff like that is that we know that when people have
adverse childhood events or trauma that could come from life experience that they've had those
things will actually affect us on all different levels of the body so people will develop auto
immune disorders which basically cancer is the body is not seeing the cancer to deal with it
appropriately right so we go in and we just ask the body okay in order to address this issue here
where do we need to start and everybody has a library of information contained in their bio field
and I'm just accessing that information through the muscle tests and the body will tell me we need to
deal with this particular issue here's a key word that that ties into that issue that they need to
think about and then we just figure out which circuit of the body we're going to correct around that
issue and what's really interesting is the way the body will drop the stress out of the system
once that that circuit has been corrected do you use things like bark flower remedies or essential
oils or acupuncture I don't I use a form of needleless acupuncture what we're actually doing is I have
a set of tools here that are made from quartz crystal that have been programmed with scalar energy
and they contain all the frequencies for all the different meridians so basically what we're doing
is we're using the meridian almost like it was a circuit board that you would find in your home
so if your breaker blows out the energy doesn't flow when you can't turn your lights on
what I'm doing is I'm just asking which circuit is blown out around this particular issue
and then in the face of that issue we retune the the meridian system and once that circuit is completed
the energy that flows in the body that also carries data that tells the cells how to work properly
it gets restored and then the body is able to start healing itself where where it couldn't before
well and that's really the basis of traditional acupuncture is that imbalance is the cause of disease
and it's really the practitioner's role is just to try to stimulate the body so that the in a
intelligence of the body can rebalance that that that issue and and break back homeostasis that's
really what you're doing with that that's right except I don't use needles for people who are
scared of it yeah well that could be an issue that could break a fear right to itself right yeah what
do you see the most common thing with seriously ill people as far as what emotions are the most
common things that come up they may have unresolved anger around things that they experience that
were done to them by other people in marriages like I've worked with a number of women who have come
out of quite terribly abusive homes or marriages and so the dealing with the fear and the anxiety
and the pain and trying to find their voice again it's been really rewarding to help restore that
to them so that they can move forward in their life and not stay trapped in it so you deal with
forgiveness and releasing some of that anger that you somebody terribly you know treated them
poorly either through sexual abuse, emotional abuse or rape or something like that and ultimately that
person you still have to forgive that person in order to release yourself you know use you can hear
that you know when you forgive somebody you're really letting yourself out of prison absolutely it's
hard to hard to come to that point for a lot of people when the pain is so deep and how do you deal
with people that think that they have forgiven somebody but really that there's still that emotional
tension there well the nice thing about this type of work is I don't have to poke or prod people to
find out and dig around in their psyche or even get them to spill their guts to me a lot of times
what people will experience if they go for traditional counseling is they they tell the story and they
relive it and they reinforce the pattern of the trauma in the telling right and then they come out
they don't feel much better than when they went in yeah when when I'm doing the work I'm asking the body
and it'll give me a representative phrase I don't have to know the context of that phrase what it
means to them I don't need to know any of the backstory I just get them to think the phrase and it
means something to them it just as an example I recently had a gal come to see me she was having
difficulty in school learning disabilities and she was going to college and was having a lot of
anxiety around it and we did a correction factor and one of the words that came up was the word
knotted and but it wasn't exactly the right word so then I had to use my Thesaurus and the word
that I eventually came to was the word Maddie so I said okay I want you to think about this word
Maddie and what it means to you and I gave her the tool that we needed to correct the circuit
and I'm thinking Maddie in terms of knotted tangled mess what it actually was was the name of her
friend oh my goodness that's how the body got me to the right word well so that is crazy yeah it's
amazing how the body works and responds it and people try to untangle that themselves it's it's um
you can take forever and you may never still untangle it and I like what you said about you know
doing talk therapy can actually be detrimental because it's reinforcing from a from a neuro
psychological understanding it's reinforcing neural pathways so you're just building that
neural pathway and reinforcing that neural pathway you're strengthening that pathway and you're you're
just you're making the problem worse when you continue to talk about it and and just reinforce the
issue that the emotion that's tied to that yes I mean we know now that the way that you think
we have a we have a saying in my line of works that your biography becomes your biology
so if you don't deal with the biography of your story of how you've got to where you are today
if you don't address those issues you will stay stuck in those patterns they're really hard to
break out of right even you know emotional stories and abusive stories you start you just continue
to relive that in your mind um you tell yourself that same story that's right and that's where the
you talk about from a spiritual standpoint we talk a lot about the freedom that's in Christ
if you can if you can turn those things over to him and let him bear that burden
it can be you know instantaneously releasing for people um but even you know when we see cancer
patients we have a lot of patients that you know are our strong believers you know in in the Lord
but they still are so stuck in certain ways and obsessed about their disease or I even obsessed
about healing and we try to tell them that's not a good place to be um and it's sometimes
difficult to talk through that with people yes well fear and creativity cannot exist in your mind
at the same time yeah fear and learning cannot take place at the same time if you're in a fearful state
like a kid who goes to school school of anxiety will not be able to learn but if you can deal with the
fear that leaves that frees you up for other options and so you know it says we're to make our bodies
a living sacrifice and that the way that we transform ourselves is through the renewing of our
mind so if you can get those stuck patterns of thinking that are in your brain if you can unstick them
I like to say that we get stumbled by life this work helps to un-stumble you and it frees you
all up to other options and other ways of being and doing things and and and it makes any of the
treatments that you're doing naturally um to support body function they just they just take off
and they work so much better when you get that junk out of the way yeah well we would love to
utilize your services and refer people your way everybody does again where your clinic is at and your
website and how to contact you uh I'm located in Prince George British Columbia Canada but people can
use your services at a distance so they don't have to travel to Canada that's right uh yes I actually
have people who have changed blood work as a result of uh seeing me so we have with objective evidence
that it works uh you can contact me by sending me a text at 250 552 3495 or you can find me on my website
at www.kinesionics.ca so k-i-n-e-s-i-o-n-i-c-s dot-c-a well thank you so much Cheryl we're gonna I
gonna ask you politely if you would be a guest again so we can continue to dig into this subject I
think it could be really helpful for a lot of people I would be delighted that would be great thank you
again and we'll see you next time okay bye for now bye bye